welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for Barbie I know not the kind
of movie trailer I normally break down
but here's the deal guys this movie is
gonna be bonkers the first teaser was a
Stanley Cooper comage and this trailer
is just referencing The Matrix and lost
I gotta talk about it Jessica Clements
you may remember did amazing breakdowns
of the past trailers but she has now
moved on from the simple Barbie land
nightmare of new rock stars to the
ringer verse but Jessica has come back
to this hell to help me so please
welcome back to New rockstars from the
ringer Jessica Clemens you know I
couldn't help myself when you were like
hey Barbie I was like
and I jumped I jumped on the chance I
was so excited to be back yes so happy
to have you back I reminded everyone
watching please support the new rock
stars Network by grabbing something from
a merch store nerd riot.shop like uh
this Miles Morales Multiverse dive shirt
and let's dive into the Barbie verse on
her rooftop we see a wide shot of Barbie
land there's a postal worker Barbie who
wears heels of course because this is
Barbie land you guys get into it Bax
instead of LAX and on the right a pink
Capitol Dome bottom right you can also
see the Chelsea doll tree house which is
like they just made a bigger scale size
of this the production team did a great
job with this the production design is
just incredible and in this shot Barbie
floats down from the roof of her house
to her car the way a kid playing with a
Barbie would gently lower the doll to
the floor and later when a reality
breaks she just kind of thunks to the
ground like a girl who suddenly gets
distracted with the cool girl next door
with the nose ring and just drops that
Barbie like it was bad news oh that was
a good one and notice how Barbie's skirt
pillows up of course uh Marilyn Monroe
dressed from the seven year Ridge
reference it's not the first time Margot
Robbie has paid homage to Marilyn Monroe
after Harley Quinn and Berta prey did
her old Gentlemen Prefer Blondes
diamonds or girls friend number yes yes
yes also behind her in her accessory box
it looks like a literal accessory box
for like when you get a first brand new
Barbie doll you see your little
accessories and a pink faux Jackie
Kennedy like Pink Suit it's gorgeous
it's great I hope we see her in it so
she's a Jackie and a Maryland she's the
best of both worlds
okay I'm not gonna touch it but I do
like that I do like that comparison oh
my God Barbie and Ken are in the
hospital because Ryan Gosling is a
Doctor Ken his pink scrubs are tied
behind his back and he rolled up his
sleeves he later tries to play doctor in
the real world clinic and has been
speculated throughout the years that
Ken's most popular profession was a
doctor and behind Ken are a lot of
flamingos of course making their beaks
into Hearts but we also see a literal
heart with EKG monitors through them and
this symbol is used on our newer Barbie
Hospital playsets there's a Barbie
sound's record which match Cuts with the
rotating floor of the Barbie's party
that's going on and it's really cute all
the music is also available to pre-order
you can buy your own Barbie sounds
lookalike vinyl on their site and I did
and I don't own a record player
I knew you were now these cans all wear
these matching golden white jumpsuits we
see constantly and we see Kinsley been a
deer you see me Lou and it's all pretty
creepy to have a bunch of K's on a white
suit next to each other KK and you know
there's third K in that line there's a
reason why Jess I think we should be
scared these guys are problematic 100
and then we see Barbie walk on the pink
sand beach she doesn't have any
Footprints in the Sand there's no Jesus
in this world only Barbie
but there's also a Barbie Statue of
Liberty in the background pledge
allegiance to the Barbie yeah church and
state of Barbie now Barbie stops the fun
dead in its tracks in this trailer do
you guys ever think about dying
there it is the existential Panic that
triggers all of this this movie is set
in a kind of meta structure like the
Matrix The Truman Show The Lego Movie
one division Jess we're back talking one
division it's awesome so Barbie land
seems like it's Barbie's dollhouse
pocket reality within the world and
there's you know this is really the
story of a child mindset thinking about
mortality for the first time and that
Millennial dread threatening the bottom
line of corporations that profit on our
bottomless Nostalgia escapism well you
said it we get an overhead shot of the
map of Barbie land a pink heart barrier
wall on the coastline it reminds us of
the satellite view of the Dome set in
Burbank of Seaside or the heck-shaped
town of Westview in Wanda Vision the
clock shaped Arena and The Hunger Games
Catching Fire what many of us thought
was the island in Lost waves crash up
against the wall does this exist in the
real world and this is another reason
why this is also so weird when Barbie
mentions all the weird things happening
to her she mentions a cold shower but
there's no shower there's no water what
is she feeling ugh I don't know I hate
it it's like the shot in Shutter Island
where he takes the sip of the water and
the shot Cuts back to it and the water
glass is empty but it's just like a
creepy like no water shot let's give me
a horror film this can be a horror film
if you just want to switch that dial
real quick and speaking of things to
Shield your eyes from Tarantino if
you're watching right now man you better
look away and go back to working on your
10 film because we see uh Margot Robbie
foot shot her pointed feet drop two flat
feet and this causes all the other
fellow Barbies to gag I love how this
one lets out a hollow Bellow like Miss
France does
hey
I love that bit I love that sketch so
much Barbie visits her Elder on the
mount played by Kate McKinnon and I'm
having a really hard time believing that
that cane that Kate McKinnon is using
isn't to support her for when she's not
doing the splits it's like only there to
support her because she's always in the
splits because we know her from the
promotional material as the Barbie
that's always in the splits a separate
trailer we see her in the splits so I'm
like this cane is only there to support
her when she's standing which is kind of
sad but I digress continue yeah she's
got this world map where it looks like
she's tried to reconstruct the little
she knows about the outside world's
geography so is this movie saying that
all Barbies are flat earthers I think so
uh we see there's Asia in Africa
Australia notices written upside down
France and then uh England has a little
crown on it we have the same shot later
that we're seeing right now the real
world this way and the last trailer the
teaser trailer came out but this will be
the two out of the three times that we
see the Warner Brothers logo they love
shoving it into this movie she plays
full homage to Morpheus in The Matrix of
red pill blue pill Choice offering two
options the high heel go back to your
reality or the flat Birkenstock and
Barbie does what we'd all do she takes a
blue pill option the first one the high
heel next the song Barbie is blasting
from her diaphragm is closer to find by
Indigo Girls because this song is for
the all ages it is for all ages yes but
mainly especially the older folks for us
this song is for us it's for us to enjoy
Barbie is maybe a millennial but also I
just think it's really nice and we now
get to see a real side of Barbie that
she chose Indigo Girls as her main theme
thank you to Harry's for sponsoring this
video but also thank you to Harry's for
making shaving easier a Harry's Razer
subscription is a true Game Changer
shaving used to be a thing I'd forget
about until it was too late like if I'm
about to record a video I don't want to
scrape up my face with an old blade I
don't have time to run to the store and
grab a new one Harry's five German
engineered blades give me the closest
tightest shave I've ever had and thanks
to their subscription program I've
always got a fresh one in hand I mean
just look at this baby pow Harry's makes
it super easy to choose what products
you get and how frequently you get them
based on your routine it's the most
convenient and most affordable way I
found to make shaving easy and
accessible if you want to try Harry's
for yourself just click the link in the
description or go to harrys.com new
rockstars to get a 13 trial set for just
five dollars and sign up to get
automatic blade refills the trial set
comes with a blade shaving gel and a
blade cover everything you need to get
started once again to get your five
dollar trial set just go to harrys.com
new rockstars and like in the John Favre
Will Ferrell classic movie Elf we get a
storybook World Travel Montage desert
then by sea and I love how Ken is afraid
of the seagull in space they're on a
rocket then they ride a tandem bike
through a tulip field in Holland and
they're camping then on a snowmobile
notice how in a lot of these though
there are strings holding up all the
two-dimensional backdrop settings in the
background yes the astronaut Barbie that
we also see is the exact Barbie from my
favorite career Barbie from the 60s you
can tell from the brown boots and the
little rectangle that she has on her
abdomen and the montages they're similar
look talking boats and Volkswagen
campers and snowmobiles from Barbie
dolls from back in the day but it's
clear the design team wanted to make the
classic Barbie accessories even more
vintage than what they look like back in
the day for this movie okay so they get
arrested they get these mug shots taken
Barbie notices five six or five seven
and her placard has a lowercase i with
the dot and then Ken's placard reads and
Ken and he's exactly six two but I just
love how Ken only exists in tandem with
Barbie and now the music we're hearing
is Mama Cass Elliot's Make Your Own Kind
of Music perhaps most famous in pop
culture sampling from Lost it's the
music Desmond plays in the swan station
season 2 premiere after they open the
hatch and the survivors of oceanic a15
cross from one reality threshold into a
deeper one thematically it's really just
a call to Define your reality for
yourself
you love lost you love lost you love
lost the Barbie land governing body led
by President Barbie Issa Ray leads some
of kenfest there are banners with horse
head and a horseshoe and this same logo
appears on the drum drum kit played by
Kinsley Ken again you get it because
it's his last name but it's a Ken
Gosling can be seen wearing his logo as
a necklace later Barbie leaving results
in a toxic Ken's Right Movement back in
Barbie land and as in The Lego Movie
Will Ferrell plays The Meta reality
villain in this case he is the Mattel
CEO yeah and additionally the
headquarters for Mattel are in El
Segundo California but you see in the
background these are some very snowy
snowy mountain peaks these are Snowy
Mountain caps I think it's another fake
backdrop or maybe we ain't actually
humans and I know in the promotional
material they said that Will Ferrell is
a human but unless he's just making fake
backdrops for the Mattel office there
are no Snowy Peaks in California yeah
where does the simulation oh yeah it's a
dollhouse in because this trailer ends
with the aqua I'm a Barbie girl in a
Barbie world which is in actually the
song that Joy was singing at the
beginning of everything everywhere all
at once but they covered her because
they didn't want to get the rights to it
and the mom covers her mouth because she
doesn't like the line uh you can uh
brush my hair undress me everywhere
oh my God I can't this game this is
gonna be a horror movie we're just
expecting it to be very fun and silly
but there's a reason it's coming out the
same day as Oppenheimer so notice how
cand is wearing this black and white
cowboy suit but with a splash of pink
with that bandana around the neck this
is the same color scheme that Will
Ferrell's CEO character wears with that
pink tie but otherwise a black and white
suit I'm wondering if he could be like
Ken Supreme of this layer of like he has
to be he has to be hey Ken I feel like
Ken's have to be him he he's the like
visualization for what Ken should be
Will Ferrell's not gonna be a good
character you guys just get ready for it
I also just want to add this is clearly
a women's jail and there's a woman in
the cell behind them there's a woman
that walks past handcuff and here's Ken
excited to be arrested it feels like
Barbie was arrested first and he forced
himself into the situation and just
followed along like which again I'm not
trying to be that person the reason why
Ken's are the problems they're just
following and not doing anything we get
the quickest flash of Michael Sarah as
Ellen dancing at the party with his gold
bow tie to suspenders notice though he
doesn't get to wear that KKK jumpsuit
attire because he is nutkin he is Ellen
what is this
and like that Alan it looks like this
Allen's doing his own dance moves he's
out of sync with everyone else but this
is important the fact that this Allen is
not a can might be the one thing that
might be able to save Barbie land from
self-destruction I think so I completely
agree with you on that Ryan Gosling's
Ken and his rival simulu can fight in a
beach battle and when they're just bump
it releases Sparkles because you know
when you're a kid and you smush two cans
together it's magic it's a little magic
I love this on this beach there are
beach chairs and umbrellas that are all
just stacked together like freaking
check the Hedgehogs you know that line
the beaches of Normandy during the D-Day
invasion World War II it just looks like
half the kids used paddle boats like the
Marines in their Landing crafts Jessica
this is insane how do they know about
this how do they know how to do this and
we hear a voice Credit in the captions
as Ruth say the line humans only have
one ending ideas live forever oh my God
I love this this is almost certainly
Ruth Handler the first president of
Mattel in the inventor of Barbie she
passed away in 2002 but it sounds like
she'll up here in some form in this
movie which is really nice A little
homage there's a quick shot of the road
leading out of Barbie land two Barbies
are driving with Alan in the back seat
they return to Barbie land if you look
at the distance it has been turned into
kendam wow yep yep the bad things are
happening when you leave the Kens alone
and then the trailer ends with our Dr
Ken assuming that he can do an
appendectomy on the desk you can see
this is a Trojan Clinic I think it's
what that says again with the horse
imagery and their association with this
masculinity hey a reminder to subscribe
to our new channels the break room in
the Deep dive and you can support this
program it's a merchant nerdwide.shop
follow Jessica at Lulu underscore
Clements and follow everything on the
ringer Network they're doing amazing
stuff over there and I can't wait to see
what you do uh you can follow me at
eavos follow new Rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars more analysis and
everything you love thanks for watching
bye everybody
[Music]
thank you